CNBC Television: This is the most severe shortage
of semiconductors in years.
KVUE ABC: The U.S. Senate passed a bill that
would give manufacturers more incentives to
make semiconductor chips.
CNA: Taiwan wants to make sure that it keeps
its leading position in the semiconductor
industry, the sector has been caught up in
U.S.-China trade tensions.
Joe BIDEN: We are in competition with China
and other countries to win the 21st Century.
We are at a great inflection point in history.
SIERRA: Right now you re hearing my voice
because of a silicon chip. Hundreds of them
in fact. You may know them by other terms,
like microchip or semiconductor. As the world
has digitized, chips have become the lifeblood
of innovation and the global economy, they
re in almost everything we use.
Access to chips can make or break a country
s economic future, and as shortages pile up,
countries are scrambling to figure out how
to ensure their access.
At the heart of the story is one company,
TSMC, which manufactures chips that are found
in everything from iPhones to fighter jets.
No other company can do what they do, and
as a result, the world depends on them. But
TSMC is located on the island of Taiwan, and
that puts it at the center of dangerous tensions
between China and the United States.
I m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It Matters,
today, our fragile relationship with the chips
that power our world.
SIERRA: So what is a silicon chip?
CLARK:Chips are the descendants of the original
transistor, which was a - kind of a switching
device. It can do all kinds of things. And
what happened is they started to put many,
many transistors on an individual piece of
silicon.
SIERRA: This is Don Clark. He has been writing
about tech for more than 30 years, including
23 as a reporter for the Wall Street Journal.
These days he s a contributor for the New
York Times.
CLARK: Now, the latest silicon chips can have
billions of tiny, tiny transistors on there
that can store data and do calculations.
HEILWEIL: So, chips are essentially the little
electronic foundation to the entire global
tech economy.
SIERRA: This is Rebecca Heilweil. She is a
reporter at Vox Recode.
HEILWEIL: These little chips are basically
powering the ins and outs of all the little
decisions that make up the devices that we
use.
CLARK: A chip is now used in just about everything
you can imagine. I was fighting this morning
with my espresso machine because it's got
chips in it, it was telling me that I couldn't
do it because I hadn't done the mandatory
cleaning it was monitoring for.
HEILWEIL: Your refrigerator, your computer,
any video game console you have, you know,
your phone.
CLARK: Your microwave, your dishwasher, your
Alexa smart speaker, your car, there are many
chips in your car.
HEILWEIL: Any kind of electronic device has
chips, and how advanced they are depends on
what kind of device you're using but they
re basically in everything right now.
SIERRA: And it's not just consumer products.
The construction equipment we use to build
homes, schools and offices requires chips.
The medical field relies heavily on them too.
And if that wasn t enough, there s another
huge driver for chip demand...data centers.
You know, the massive server systems that
power the entire internet, from Google to
Linkedin to Reddit. Every time you use these
services, there are chips on the other side
providing the information.
CLARK: People particularly notice this now
that we're streaming everything in our lives,
from Netflix, to homeschooling to whatever.
But for the big broadcasters in the old days,
if they were broadcasting over the air, people
could log on with their TVs, but they didn't
have to do anything to their facilities, they
were just beaming the signals to all these
different people. In the broadband streaming
era, each person that logs on, basically,
they have to buy more computing capacity to
serve that person. So the more streams there
are, the more chips are consumed.
SIERRA: Every photo uploaded to Instagram,
every video on YouTube. All of it requires
more computing power. To stay in the tech
race, countries need a steady stream of new
chips. But before we can understand their
geopolitical importance, we first have to
understand a bit more about how the chip industry
works. So, we all know that computing power
gets better over time. Every few years we
re offered a new generation of smartphones,
gaming consoles, and laptops that are faster
and more powerful than ever before. A lot
of this progress is fueled by improvements
to chips. But it doesn t just happen. In order
to push forward, scientists and engineers
have to figure out how to pack more and more
transistors into the same space, and companies
invest billions to help them do it. When they
succeed, the payoff is huge. Last year the
semiconductor industry reported $439 billion
in revenue.
SIERRA: We must be making them by the millions
right now. I mean, how big is the demand?
CLARK: Well, trillions.
SIERRA: Trillions!
CLARK: I mean, literally, trillions of chips
get made every year. And they go from the
price of less than a penny to thousands of
dollars. So there's many different varieties
of these things.
SIERRA: Do you think that you can give me
a sort of step by step of how a chip is produced?
What do the supply chains look like?
CLARK: The supply chains are incredibly complicated.
It starts with raw materials. So you have
silicon, which is the ingredient in sand.
And so they make this big cylinder thing.
And then they slice it up and make wafers,
which are usually 12 inches across. And then
they start laying down and taking off materials
from those wafers. And the most important
step is called photolithography where they
trace the patterns of circuitry on those for
each chip that's going to be made on the wafer.
There's a particular company called ASML in
the Netherlands, which dominates that photolithography
step. But they now make a machine called an
extreme ultraviolet lithography machine, each
one of these machines is about $150 million
a pop. It's probably the most complicated
machine humans have ever created. And they
are the only supplier of it. After that, all
these chemicals are added, things are etched,
things are baked. Things are laid on. Anyway,
once they have that wafer created, they cut
it up with these diamond saws to create the
individual chips, and they're sent to separate
companies that wrap them in plastic and make
little connectors around them. And then they
test them. And so really, the whole supply
chain gets really complicated because it includes
all the raw materials. It includes all those
companies that make machines that are used
to do all these processing steps. It includes
the companies that have the big factories,
the big fabs, they're called like TSMC, and
Intel and Samsung. And then there's the companies
that package them and test them. And then
various levels of purchasers and buyers and
sellers. So they'd say now this, by some estimates,
that the average chip crosses a national border
70 times before it reaches its end destination.
SIERRA: Wow. That's quite a lot of steps.
Quite a lot of travel for one little chip.
SIERRA: And guess what? If we thought demand
was high before, the pandemic kicked it into
overdrive. Netflix added 37 million users.
Zoom went from 10 million to 300 million daily
meeting participants. All of these processes
need chips. To understand this better, we
spoke to Ajit Manocha, the president and CEO
of SEMI, the world s leading semiconductor
industry association.
MANOCHA: So we're on a growth path to start
with, and then the pandemic hit us. Now, what
did the pandemic do? Immediately we went homeschooling,
working from home. We stopped coming to the
offices. Social media companies became pretty
big. The number of laptops and the mobile
devices that we needed last year was unprecedented.
I mean, I give the example, I have three grandkids
in the ages of three to six. Each one of them
have two devices. They are homeschooling,
they have their own laptop or iPad, and they
know how to turn it on and how to communicate
with the class, how to sit in the Zoom classroom.
So, imagine it's going on all over the world.
Virtually, every semiconductor company is
reporting record revenue. The demand is high.
SIERRA: When supply chains are stretched to
their max, and demand continues to increase,
you end up with shortages. And that s exactly
what happened over the last year. The consequences
were so serious that even now, as vaccinations
are rolling out in many countries, shortages
and product delays continue to pile up. And
the product that got hit hardest during the
pandemic is not one you d immediately associate
with chips....cars.
SIERRA: You've written about how over the
last year, we've seen this chip shortage due
to the pandemic affecting global supply chains.
So do you think you can take me sort of step
by step through that story, sort of how it
started and who it ended up affecting?
HEILWEIL: Sure. So at the beginning of the
pandemic, some automakers were sort of estimating,
okay, the pandemic means there's going to
be an economic crisis. And obviously, people
aren't going to be buying as many cars. So
we're going to basically jump off the line
for chips, because we don't think we're going
to need as many. Then suddenly, things reverse.
And the economic recovery starts happening
again. And some car manufacturers want to
basically get back on line, get their chips,
but suddenly, there's all these device makers
who have been demanding chips the entire time.
And now, the automakers are still dealing
with that shortage and trying to catch up.
And at the baseline, it takes a while to get
a chip, it's not like you can just call up
a chip manufacturer and say, Hi, I need like
10,000 more chips next week, can you just
make some extra, that's not how it works.
We're talking about weeks and weeks and weeks
of lead time. And now we see GM and companies
like that having to leave their workers idle
and, and close down factories, because there
aren't enough chips to keep their manufacturing
going. And in the US, that's a real pain point,
because there are so many auto workers and
that's a population a lot of people really,
really care about.
CBS46: Car dealerships are bracing for lean
months as computer chips shortages are causing
supply nightmares thanks to the pandemic.
CBS46: Kia will shut down for two days due
to supply issues.
Reuters: Hyundai is the latest firm to say
it is paying a price for the global shortage
of computer chips.
ABC10: It s not just here we are feeling the
impact, it is everywhere throughout our nation.
Now keep in mind the vast majority of new
cars are built with these computer chips.
So in short, no computer chips, no new cars.
SIERRA: That seems like a real fragile system
right there.
CLARK: It is fragile. And, back when we were
having a shortage of personal protective equipment
coming from China, people started thinking,
hey, you know, some things are strategic,
we can't rely on foreign places to supply
some of these things that are just really
necessary. So between the shutdown of the
auto plants, which cost a lot of union workers
their jobs, I mean, that puts a lot of pressure
on a democratic president. Meanwhile, you
had this kind of gradual feeling that the
US was getting too dependent on foreign suppliers,
even allies in Taiwan and South Korea. So
there's been a separate push in Washington
to help the semiconductor industry and they're
now proposing a $50 billion infusion to help
spur more US manufacturing.
SIERRA: In fact, since our interview with
Don, the Senate passed a $250 billion bill
that aimed at boosting U.S. tech competitiveness,
including $52 billion for chip production.
And the U.S. isn t alone. Countries all over
the world have recognized that access to chips
is essential, and they are making big investments
in an attempt to reduce their dependence on
other countries. The epicenter of that dependence
is TSMC, located one hundred miles off China
s coast on the island of Taiwan. TSMC s rise
has left rivals like Intel almost a decade
behind, and made it one of the world s most
valuable companies. At the same time it has
become a target of U.S.-China competition,
and according to some analysts, could even
pull the United States into armed conflict.
More on that after the break.
SIERRA: I wanted to tell you about another
podcast I think you ll like: The Last Archive
from Harvard historian and New Yorker writer
Jill Lepore. This season, Lepore is investigating
purveyors of doubt hoaxers, fraudsters, pseudoscientists
and how the peddling of doubt evolved over
the 20th century, leading all the way to the
Capitol Insurrection on January 6, 2021. This
show is unlike anything you ve heard before:
history animated by long lost archival tapes
and documents, intrepid reporting, and radio
drama reenactments. The Last Archive unfurls
like a classic 1930s gumshoe mystery but takes
on the big issues of today. How do we know
what we know, and why does it seem, sometimes,
lately, as if we don t know anything at all?
Listen to The Last Archive wherever you get
your podcasts. From Pushkin Industries.
SIERRA: To understand TSMC s enormous power,
you have to understand their place in the
global semiconductor industry. Companies like
Intel, Samsung, and AMD design chips. TSMC,
on the other hand, doesn t design chips at
all, it simply takes the designs from clients
and then manufactures them. It wasn t always
this way. Most designers used to manufacture
their own chips. Intel still does. But as
the semiconductor business grew over the years,
skyrocketing demand and high manufacturing
costs prompted many designers to outsource
the manufacturing process to third-party fabrication
plants.
MANOCHA: Morris Chang who is founder of TSMC,
he came up with the idea that why not we create
a wafer fab foundry, where we will actually
put all the investments and manufacture for
the companies who are very good in designing
chips. And the manufacturing companies will
take the blueprints and they will start fabricating
based upon what the chip is supposed to be
in final shape. And TSMC did a very good job
of making that happen, and pretty soon, people
realize this is very good business for us.
Now, we can spend more money and time and
effort on chip design and design a lot more
chips instead of spending more money on building
fabs.
SIERRA: TSMC has gotten better at it than
anyone else on earth, earning 39,000 patents
for their manufacturing process along the
way. Today they serve over 500 clients, including
Apple, Sony, Huawei, Alibaba, and the U.S.
Department of Defense.
SACKS: When you look at the company, it's
staggering. They just announced that they're
going to invest $100 billion in the next three
years. They are absolutely at the leading
edge and there are very few, if any competitors.
SIERRA: $100 billion, by one company, that
s almost twice as much as the spending approved
by the U.S. Senate. This is David Sacks, by
the way. He is a research fellow at the Council,
where his work focuses on U.S.-China relations,
U.S.-Taiwan relations, and Chinese foreign
policy.
SACKS: So around 90% of the world's most advanced
chips are made by TSMC on Taiwan. And of course,
Taiwan is a geopolitical flashpoint for the
United States and for China.
SIERRA: Taiwan and China have a volatile relationship,
which puts global chip supplies at risk. In
order to understand this risk, we need to
do a bit of history. In the aftermath of World
War II, China underwent a long and bloody
civil war. There were two factions: the Nationalists,
and the Chinese Communist Party. In 1949,
the Nationalists were defeated, and fled to
their stronghold on the island of Taiwan.
Since then, Taiwan has been governed independently
from mainland China, with its own currency,
passports, and military. Still, Beijing maintains
that Taiwan is and always will be part of
its territory. For a long time now the schism
has been a very touchy issue; for China, for
Taiwan, and for countries that want to interact
with them. At the heart of the problem is
a single worry: will China someday invade
Taiwan in an attempt to reunify the island?
SACKS: Today Taiwan is a thriving democracy
with multiple peaceful transitions of power,
firm civilian control over the military and
a vibrant civil society. And from the Chinese
perspective, Taiwan is viewed as a symbol
that the civil war is not yet over. They believe
that Taiwan has to become a part of China
sooner or later, and they have reserved the
right to use force to bring that about. The
United States official position is that Taiwan's
future is to be determined. So we don't take
a view on Taiwan's legal status. But what
we do emphasize is that anything that happens
with respect to Taiwan has to come about peacefully
and with the consent of the people on Taiwan.
But still the United States has certain commitments
to Taiwan under the Taiwan Relations Act,
namely to provide Taiwan with defensive weapons
and to maintain the capacity to come to Taiwan's
defense without actually saying that the United
States will come to Taiwan's defense during
a crisis.
SIERRA: If you re a bit confused it s not
your fault. U.S. policy on Taiwan is ambiguous
by design, and it centers on having the ability
to defend Taiwan from China while not committing
to do so. It has always been a very touchy
situation. And now the world s most advanced
and important chip manufacturer has been added
to the mix.
SACKS: If China is able to take over Taiwan,
it can project power into the Pacific from
the east coast of Taiwan. It can essentially
regulate shipping in the South China sea and
exert leverage on shipping lanes that end
up in South Korea and Japan. So those are
the traditional arguments that have been given
for why the United States should defend Taiwan.
But with the emergence of TSMC, and a growing
recognition of its centrality to the global
economy and to the technologies of the future
including military technologies, it is increasingly
part of the debate. So should the United States
defend Taiwan's democracy? Should it defend
Taiwan because of its strategic location?
And also, should it defend Taiwan because
it is the world's only producer of the leading
edge semiconductors? And how critical that
is for US defense applications, for instance.
SIERRA: I recently heard someone call TSMC
Taiwan's silicon shield . So how important
is the company for Taiwan and its goals?
SACKS: So I think that Taiwan and TSMC both
understand the centrality of TSMC to Taiwan.
So for instance, Taiwan is having to ration
water right now for the island because it
didn't have the same storms that it usually
gets. And what it's been doing is, it s let
all the water flow to TSMC that it needs to
produce semiconductors, and it's rationing
it for households elsewhere. And to me, that
really reveals that Taiwan understands the
importance of TSMC to its economy, to its
society and also strategically.
SIERRA: So, Taiwan understands that TSMC raises
its profile, and makes it a more essential
partner across the world. The United States
understands that without TSMC, it would lose
access to the chips that keep its economy
and military moving. And China, for its part,
is navigating many of the same fears.
SACKS: China's fears have already manifested
themselves, which is that the United States
has been able to get TSMC to stop selling
chips to Chinese companies like Huawei. And
while China likes to throw a lot of money
at problems like this, and assume that if
it just spends billions and billions of dollars
it can catch up with TSMC, it has so far made
very little progress. It's still years behind
TSMC. And while it's trying to catch up with
TSMC, TSMC is already working on the next
level.
SIERRA: Are we worried that semiconductors
might pave the road to conflict? I mean, how
do we avoid the trap of thinking that conflict
is just inevitable?
SACKS: Yeah. So to put this in perspective,
China's official line is that it still prefers
peaceful unification. And so, what that means
is actually using an array of coercive tactics,
short of force, to convince the Taiwanese
people that their future is inextricably tied
to China. And that the best outcome for them
is unification with the mainland. And so,
I think it's important to still keep in mind
that using force is their last option.
SIERRA: Will China eventually attempt to reunify
Taiwan by force? If they did, would it pull
the United States into war? And would the
U.S. and other countries lose access to TSMC
s chips if China succeeded? These aren t questions
you commonly hear in the tech world, but they
are the questions that many countries are
asking themselves as shortages spread and
tensions increase. As a result, many have
decided that microchips should be considered
strategically essential, and that they should
spend billions to figure out how to make them
on their own.
Arirang News: Prompted by the crippling Semiconductor
supply crunch around the world, U.S. President
Joe Biden held a meeting with business leaders,
stressing the need to invest in what he called
semiconductor infrastructure.
Joe BIDEN: I have received a letter from 23
senators, bipartisan letter, and 42 house
members republican and democrat. Supporting
the chips for America program. I ve been saying
for some time now, China and the rest of the
world is not waiting, and there is no reason
why Americans should wait.
CNBC: So Beijing has made chips a top priority
for its 5 year plan. Independence is one of
5 fundamentals" of China s economic development.
SIERRA: But as it turns out chip independence
can t just be built overnight.
SACKS: So president Biden has $50 billion
for the semiconductor industry in his infrastructure
package, but that's just a drop in the bucket.
The semiconductor industry association estimates
that the United States would have to spend
north of $1 trillion over a decade to become
self-sufficient for its chips. It's going
to be very hard to become self-sufficient
because it's frankly just cheaper to build
these in Taiwan and Taiwan has the engineering
talent already in place. So it's going to
be very difficult for the United States to
close this gap.
CLARK: In the semiconductor business, they
talk about the learning curve, which is all
about making more working chips on each wafer,
and getting their yield up. So you're more
profitable and more productive. And so you
just have to keep producing these things,
to learn all the little tweaks and knobs and
temperature settings and chemical adjustments
you gotta make. So there is a tendency, once
a company gets in front, for them to stay
in front.
SIERRA: That doesn t mean the U.S. is giving
up the chase. If the Senate-approved bill
passes in its current form, it would provide
$52 billion over five years to boost chip
production and research. Intel plans to spend
$20 billion to build two new plants. And the
U.S. is subsidizing TSMC s new $12 billion
factory in Arizona. Other world leaders are
making big moves too - the EU plans to invest
up to $60 billion in chip design and production
over the next 2-3 years. China plans to invest
$118 billion as part of its most recent five
year plan. Chip production is expensive. But
money isn t the only factor.
SIERRA: Is part of this competition a race
to get the best and brightest minds in the
industry?
CLARK: It is. It is very much so. And, you
know, all these companies hire, you know,
all the PhDs they can and all the best electrical
engineers and computer scientists, you know,
the US educational institutions produce the
best. Not the not the greatest number, necessarily,
but the best and, but right now, I think that
the stats are like 60% or so of the students
pursuing PhDs in those disciplines are foreign
born. So a lot of them tried to work here
and use their educational degree to help get
a job here and stay in America, but the Trump
administration made that very difficult. And
meanwhile, companies got stronger abroad.
So some people say from Taiwan, for example,
who would have wanted to stay here, you know,
cycle back to Taiwan, same thing was true
in mainland China, I think. So it is a race
and consequently the semiconductor industry
association and people like that have lobbied
hard for immigration policies that make it
easier for people to move from country to
country and for educated people to stay here.
SIERRA: Yeah, I mean, because traditionally,
we think of the US as having an advantage
in getting the world's brightest minds, but
it seems like we may be losing that advantage.
CLARK: Yeah in my opinion, we're shooting
ourselves in the foot because I think we should,
you know, staple a green card to every PhD
in electrical engineering, you know.
SACKS: In a sense it shows that the United
States doesn't have the talent that it once
had. I mean, it's under-invested in R&D and
it's undressed under-invested in STEM education.
And interestingly, if you listen to TSMC's
founder, he will say that the United States
doesn't have the engineering talent to make
it viable for TSMC to relocate these operations
to the country. And he will point to Taiwan's
engineers as a big asset for TSMC going forward.
MANOCHA: So you can invest all the money,
have a fab, but if you can't hire people,
that's going to be a problem. I think that's
the way things are shaping up now. When countries
start declaring the importance of semiconductors
for nationalistic reasons. There are two parts
of this answer. The policy will be okay, whatever
I need to do to support the semiconductor
industry in my country, policies will be in
that view. But the good thing is, the second
part of this is that there's no one country
who can do everything from start to finish.
Okay, so you have to depend on multiple countries.
So the policy makers will definitely start
thinking, my gosh, this is a global supply
chain. We need to collaborate more with like-minded
countries who are part of the integrated supply
chain, and we need to make sure not just only
looking it from the nationalistic point of
view, but also from a global point of view
that we got to work together with multiple
countries, because this supply chain is interdependent
on many countries to make a chip.
SIERRA: Chips have become an irreplaceable
part of our world. We need them for every
call we make, every visit to the doctor, every
show we watch, every car we build. They re
critical to economic growth, innovation, and
defense. The need to create them can lead
to good things - investment in STEM education,
alliances, fruitful competition between researchers,
and technological breakthroughs that better
our world. But like any other essential resource,
they also have the power to fuel divisiveness,
trade disputes, nationalism and even armed
conflict. The world is learning just how much
it depends on them. And that it can no longer
tolerate the fragility revealed during the
pandemic. We need a better system. But what
type of system will we build? For resources
used in this episode and more information,
visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and take a look
at the show notes. Have a question or some
feedback? Just feel like saying hey? Send
us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org. Subscribe
to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher,
or wherever you get your audio. And if you
are a fan of the show, we d love if you could
leave us a review. Ideally a good one, with
five stars. It really does help us get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The show is created
and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy Sherlick,
and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer
is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert is our
assistant podcast producer. Sophie Yass is
our summer intern. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Extra help for this episode was provided
by Zoe Han and Anshu Siripurapu. Original
music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen. Special
thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off. See you soon!